tu attendais
tambourin jamais l'oublier
maintenant là on n'est qu'un exemple
mais bon mais même moi qui n'aime pas le
football dit tout je me suis prise j'ai
zéro genre et dénis finale et tout ça à
klaxonner dans la voiture comme une
andouille alors que j'aurais trouvé ça
stupide six mois avant et c'est moi on
était tous avec vous je vois pourquoi
tous les gens que vous pensez réunis à
l'alliance entier c'est la première fois
depuis de chemin depuis la libération de
malgré ça vous êtes très critiqué sur la
préparation de l'euro 2000
vous décidez de plus parler à la presse
pendant le championnat d'europe oui
c'est ça mais c'est pas simplement les
critiques les critiques elles ont
utilisé toujours acceptées elles font
partie du métier comme on dit mais
lorsqu'on en arrive à ce soit des
articles malsain ou avoir jusqu'à
l'incompétence bon ça ne m'intéressait
pas de répondre à certaines personnes
malheureusement ce n'est pas la majorité
des journalistes et je le regrette
comique il faut le dire en particulier
oui ce soir certains ça tous les
journalistes l'équipe astana qui sont
bons aussi quoi c'est pas il y en a
certains qui ont mal fait leur travail
ou qui ont cherché à mécontents après la
victoire que vous aviez obtenu avec
l'équipe de france à la coupe du monde
comment dans les années qui ont suivi
vous pouvez être tant critiqué les
guignols qui en remettent une couche
comme le dit si bien aimé jacquet commun
non mais comment ça se fait qu'on nous
l'expliqué s'avoue l'image des guignols
bon je pensais jamais y être parce que
j'avais pas quelque chose de particulier
qu'ils pouvaient me faire rentrer d'un
vélo pour devenir le dauphin louis bès
de la fonction aussi quoi mais je crois
pas que je vais dit souvent cette phrase
aimé jacquet heureusement l'a dit lui
même c'est vrai que j'ai souvent eu des
accrochages avec lui parce qu'on n'était
pas forcément d'accord mais bon c'est
pas bien méchant mais les critiques
c'est comme ça on a été champions du
monde et on a une une période de
qualification pour l'euro qui a été très
difficile où on lisait il faut les
changer tout le monde et il n'y avait
que des donneurs de leçons les mêmes qui
avaient critiqué aimé jacquet avant la
coupe du monde et après il était obligé
de reconnaître que c'était quand même un
bon on n'a plus l'air commencé à
critiquer le maire et vous oui le maire
évident
dans la lignée du jacquet certainement
moi aussi parce que bon j'étais un peu
l'héritier de jacques et ont été blessés
par les propos d'un coéquipier qui a dit
en parlant de vous dis dit il est cramé
et le 2 septembre au dernier match donc
vous allez le voir et vous lui dites je
sais exactement les propos que j'ai
tenus sur moi voulait ce qui se dit
c'est un des joueurs non je pense me le
fait que je me sois éliminé c'est à dire
que j'ai laissé l'équipe de france ça
pose plus aucun problème il peut
continuer moi je continue pas si j'avais
eu à continuer ça aurait certainement
poser des problèmes parce que quelqu'un
qui qui qui m'a trahie et j'aime pas ça
surtout de l'intérieur ce que je
réagissais oui évidemment mais aussi de
ses fils que je lui ai dit mais vous moi
j'ai mis huit mois avant de savoir mais
je vais vous le dire c'est hélas
impossible et s'il joue en équipe
nationale bien bon donc vous êtes
critiqué tout ça mais malgré tout quand
même il ya ça